our state's primary elections have come
to an end but you may still see some
candidate signs lingering at those empty
lots just all across all over the valley
and some residents say it's just become
an eyesore that's led to vandalism
heather mills shows us when we can
expect to see those signs coming down
nobody asked us if we wanted election
signs to put up in our neighborhood and
now that they're there nobody's taking
them down it's an annoyance to some a
lot of times they just remain for weeks
and months on end an eyesore for others
and some residents say it's even a
breeding ground for vandalism
it's been a heated election season with
candidates taking to tv screens
and the streets to get your vote
the primary elections wrapped up on june
15th but these signs remain scattered
throughout clark county it's like a
magnet for vandalism for people to like
spray paint on them or do like weird
stuff on them and that's not why we
moved here while it may be considered
blight the signs still standing aren't
illegal in fact candidates have 15 days
after the elections are called to take
them down but only if that candidate
lost even if it might be legal to do so
it doesn't mean that it's right well
come july first many of the signs should
be gone at least until november when
election season picks up once again this
eyesore but
you know after the election they should
be taken down heather mills live local
now